ma chronique audio secondes
il est droit je pourrais m lucas qui ont
lire et lucas quoi tellement cet homme
étant en perpendiculaire mans ok ta
gueule attendez ce que le vieux est en
train de faire un solo de guitare
actuellement api quiz allez c'est parti
ou la peau d'âne apinac et 100 espagnole
tout s'en va
matt snipe à 2014 qu'est ce qu'on fait
what je sais que ça aille john powell
est ce qui est ce qui se fait braquer
par un fusil volant oui j'ai pas
d'argent
donne moi ta gueule voilà c'est tout ce
que j'ai je te donne mon bras peut-être
voit le magal le fusil kidnapper les
gens très bien impossible pro je relève
le défi jeune homme au et voilà toute
chose et soyaux non israël existe prime
abord this way mais je m'attendais
tellement à mourir mon gars il ne m'a
pas menti je suis j'ai eu raison de lui
faire confiance
je te croirais plus jamais attendez on
m'a greffer gens voter ton là qui sait
c'est que ces délires et est ce que
notre personnage tentera de faire une
crise d'épilepsie
oui comme dans tous les jeux on pourrait
presque croire qu'il attend big mac the
ce leader board
tu viens de tuer quel personnage 2 1
rite aid black swan mais ça me disent ah
qu'est ce que c'est ouais
à quel niveau incroyable voilà la tour
eiffel dans 20 ans laissez moi avant oh
je peux voir mettez tout maintenant
l'homme aux plus gros torticolis
mondiale oh oui oui papa je voulais moi
aussi papa
l'espoir est et où je m'en vais
escalader le mont blanc aux débutants la
crêpe ou sera au soir dont oui oh oui ça
me plaît j'aime bien aller on va prendre
vie j'aime tellement lancé les épées et
à mais arrête de tom brocher mon gars on
l'appelait le wolverine du dos dans le
jargon qu'est ce que c'est que cette
chose alors roger cela mieux l'attisé
mont moïse comme ça comment tuer le père
noël fire un homme se c'est dégueulasse
pour des messies cadeau et vous l'avez
tué ouais on a gagné
[ __ ] fallait du skill quand même hein
alala 8,8 à j'aime quand tu me fais un
massage des pieds comme ça fiston oh oui
j or au oui à un peu plus comme ça je
veux pour bassin ce buzz bois we prod
oui si vous pouviez prévenir un petit
peu plus tôt peut-être que je pourrai
courir le niveau s'appelle comment faire
du jus d'orange
je sens la blague nul voila c'était sur
aaa
ayew died je m'emballe stakes abuse
parce que maintenant ça les tchèques
j'ai raté l'épée hommes je t'attrape par
le cul et je touchais tu laisses moi
prod plaimont mais non non pas le retour
de la malédiction du sabre dans le cul
coptes qui de se prendre à l'épée en
premier c'est le plus grand tournoi du
monde
et voilà maintenant je ne peux ni glitch
je parie un grec à chacun d'entre vous
que c'est un truc pervers c'est sûr ils
adorent ça dont je doive et c'est
impossible
bon j'ai enquêté mélanie melania de
pédaler tués dans le vide mais l'ani a
dit suivre
je suis la boulbène ou rue paper optical
test où j'ai bien fait j'ai moins je
veux plus aller jusque là faute ma vie
je vais produire assez d'électricité
pour faire un café tous les deux mois
regardez ça veut dire que je marchais
tiens on dirait qu'ils dansent quoi et
dans le prochain clip de beyoncé c'est
sûr mais qu'est-ce qui fait loterie bas
ils coutu et 2 mai que c est ce que
c'est une araignée mais [ __ ] c'est un
matin son clip
hélas trop à gauche il s'est invité à la
whey c'est un niveau pourquoi tu
commences tu te fais déjà coupé la tête
plongée enquête
attendez on voit la festo tu veux
toujours rêvé d'être superman
je vois la dame arrête fist aurore papa
j'espère y aller avant ce geste on tue
le fiston c'est l'histoire d'un père et
son fils qui voulaient voir une femme à
moitié nue flapi bird version happy with
au [ __ ] vous remarquerez en trop de
ballons qui essaient de chatouiller
l'autre moitié de mon corps oui c'est
couci voulzy et l'autre qui regarde ça
comme c'était le nouveau film de tim
burton
non non c'est juste un petit asticot de
jambes
voilà c'est j'avais compris le niveau à
rim cheika ce parti auld space j'aurais
plutôt dit le niveau exercice peut voir
la [ __ ] qu'est-ce qu'il avait un truc
derrière lui je vous la fais en jetant
peut-être qu'au montage
ça lui a alors ah c'est pas du tout
harlem shakes et un chacun aux macarons
l'arlem shake est paraplégique
jb oui mme jennings live maasing master
mode
mes oreilles très bien le personnage
s'est transformé en poissons magique
harpe mais le voici
et maintenant un nouveau d'ivoire les
tchèques qui fonctionne toujours aussi
mal papapapa pop pop pop la fête est nul
je m'en vais le mignon dictateur sait
très bien merci médiocre grâce à toi
j'embrasse le crâne chauve d'un homme 27
et un de mes plus grands rêves question
je me suis pris la ville
oui c'est mais pas je problème est papa
ouais vous faites bien à propos j'adore
faire le tour comme ça comment fais tu
sais on attendait voilà tu vas faire le
bouclier anti-émeute par contre retire
ta main de mon zizi retire ta avoir de
bons calçots [ __ ] de pervers mais
retire tabac ou engagement mais voilà je
m'en vais voilà je préfère mourir parmi
tout le monde
bon bah voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin
de ce troisième petit best-of sur happy
pulse est ce parce que nous on a pu
aussi se trouvent déjà partie soit dans
une nouvelle vidéo sur marie chantal
j'espère que ça vous a plu je vous dis à
très vite sur le monde mx2 deux gros
coups de ce que c'est tu te rends compte
ou pas or pour les oiseaux qui a des
lèvres les yeux je parle de nombre 1
c'est une fille byrne j'aime bien là ah
ah ça va bien à quand il n'est pas sur
la chute de 20 mètres